we've seen the headlines russia
attacking the largest nuclear plant in
europe president putin mobilizing
russia's nuclear deterrence forces which
include nuclear weapons and the power
being cut at chernobyl raising the
prospect of a nuclear accident nuclear
threats and nuclear radiation are scary
but what happens to the human body when
we get exposed to radioactive material
let's see what we can learn from history
okay first let's go back to chernobyl
but in 1986
a surge in power during a test resulted
in a steam explosion and a fire that
released large amounts of radioactive
material it was an old style soviet
reactor that didn't have full
containment that's norman kleiman a
radiation expert at columbia university
he said that because of that when the
reactor blew it was able to spew a cloud
of radioactive material into the
atmosphere that radioactive material is
just atoms that are unstable and can
damage cells that radioactive cloud then
spread around the world among the people
who were most affected were plant
workers and first responders people who
were exposed to very high radiation
levels very quickly i'm going to give
you a unit it's called one sievert
that's what some of the workers at
chernobyl were exposed to that led to
acute exposure symptoms like vomiting
dizziness diarrhea nausea damage to the
digestive system and severe burns
basically you're killing all the
dividing cells in your body and it's a
horrible horrible horrible thing in the
months after chernobyl about 100 people
suffered from that acute exposure and
about 30 people died it's that big quick
hit that makes radiation exposure so
dangerous but thankfully disasters of
that magnitude are pretty rare about 25
years after chernobyl a powerful
earthquake caused a tsunami that damaged
the fukushima nuclear power plant in
japan triggering a meltdown but in
contrast to chernobyl workers at the
fukushima power plant were exposed to
radiation levels that were about 10
times lower no one got a dose big enough
to trigger the acute effects seen at
chernobyl
beyond the immediate acute risks
scientists also look at the long-term
ramifications of nuclear radiation
exposure including an increased risk of
cancer a united nations report found
that workers from chernobyl had a
slightly increased chance of leukemia
and some developed cataracts people who
lived in the area also got exposed to
radiation it's in that population that
the most clear connection between cancer
and radiation exposure exists their
exposure came from consuming
contaminated food particularly milk that
was contaminated with radioactive iodine
that radioactive iodine made its way
into the thyroid where damaged cells the
thyroid is a gland involved in
controlling metabolism so after three
months it's gone but that first three
months you want to avoid food stops that
are contaminated there's been about 6
000 cases of thyroid cancer reported so
far among children exposed to
radioactive iodine after chernobyl 15 of
them died but the vast majority 95
were treated successfully apart from the
increased risk of thyroid cancer that un
report didn't find any increased risk
for other kinds of cancer in the general
population
so if the data isn't as bad as we may
have thought why are we so anxious about
radiation exposure part of it is that
it's invisible we don't understand
radiation we can't smell it we can't see
it we can't taste it we don't know if
we're being exposed but we're scared of
it one of the major misconceptions about
radiation exposure is that its adverse
effects are heritable meaning that they
get passed down from parents to their
children
some of those fears date back to world
war ii when the u.s dropped two atomic
bombs on japan after the atomic bombings
all the media all the press even
scientists believed the heritable
effects were the real outcome to worry
about not true a key study from april
found that there weren't any radiation
related genetic changes passed on from
parents to children among chernobyl
survivors
one of the most common impacts of
radiation exposure might actually be the
most overlooked the world health
organization by far says the largest
health outcome of any radiological
disaster is mental health fear anxiety
and adoption of unhate unhealthy
behaviors because of this misperception
about real risk versus relative risk in
other words nuclear disasters cause a
lot of trauma all this adds up to what
the u.n report described as serious
social and psychological disruption so
where does that leave us norman
reiterated that no level of radiation
was a hundred percent safe but we had to
gauge that risk against other health
hazards he said that for low levels of
exposure the kind you might get while
you're flying in an airplane or even at
the chernobyl site today the risks are
pretty low the health risks from
drinking or smoking are actually higher
we now know that a higher risk of cancer
after chernobyl was only seen in a
subset of people mostly children who ate
contaminated food that could have been
prevented if people had been told to
avoid potentially contaminated food or
if there had been iodine pills available
soon after the disaster norman told me
that these pills only work to keep
radioactive iodine out of the thyroid if
they're given within 24 hours of
exposure major problems arise when
precautions aren't taken to mitigate
risks that's the main takeaway from
chernobyl and other major nuclear
disasters we've experienced
if you found this video informative hit
the like button and don't forget to hit
subscribe thank you for watching i
gracias
[Music]